[Music]
when embarking on a road trip it's
important to know and trust the people
you're traveling with as well as being
aware of what they're gonna bring to the
journey who is navigator for example
designated driver
and of course designated sniper okay so
the last one is unconventional but when
your road trip is in fact a
trans-siberian railroad colep t'k
partially irradiated Russian continent
than trust me it is needed in Metro
Exodus your vehicle for the
aforementioned trip is also your home
say hello to the Aurora
hello Aurora this tricked-out steam
train is packed with a crew of Spartan
Rangers characters as varied as the
mutants which inhabit the desolate
wasteland but thankfully better-looking
so just who is along for the ride on
this journey in search of life after
nuclear war here are 11 characters you
need to know before hopping aboard and
Metro Exodus
[Music]
first up we have Artyom the player
avatar and protagonist for the whole
Metro series born roughly four years
before the bombs fell Artyom has little
to no memory of pre-war life and he's a
first generation child of the Metro
tunnels Artyom is now a Spartan Ranger
and like the rest of that order lives in
d6 a disused pre-war top-secret
government facility I should say lived
really because a huge train can have
destroyed d6 at the end of the previous
game Metro last light ironically he and
his surviving Spartans now live on a
train not the same train though I
checked Artyom is convinced that there
is human life out there beyond the Metro
and he intends to find it while we don't
know much about his personality due to
his role as player surrogate we do know
that he has heroic tendencies and has
risked his life for his fellow man on
more than one occasion
there's no doubt he cares for his
companions and none more so than his
wife Anna Anna is a formidable fighter
and the top sniper in the whole spartan
order Artyom and Anna met during the
events of Metro last light and although
they didn't hit it off at first during
some time spent in quarantine together
one thing led to another and they rode
the rails if you get my drift
Anna is our team's key advisor on
missions and provides support when need
calls for him to venture into the
wilderness anna is known for her
indomitable personality but while
ultimately being kind at heart she is a
devotee Granger and follows orders well
most of which come from her father
Miller tomb Amelia what is the message
from huntin Miller is head of the
Rangers of the order and a regular
character in the Metro series playing a
role in booth 2033 and last light the
war is coming and I'll need every ranger
at his post though his appearance has
changed his gruff leadership style has
not which he now brings to the role of
commander of the Aurora he is rational
and calculating well the tendency to be
shall we say forthright just only
mithril nothing else during the fight
for d6 miller was badly injured and lost
both of his legs when that train smashed
into the base this doesn't stop him
getting around though and he's now
equipped with metal
prosthetics the rest of the characters
on board the Aurora are new to the Metro
series so at this point there's not a
lot we can say about them here is what
we do know though in the form of a
quick-fire character reveal Stefan is a
heavy weapons specialist and giant of a
man he has been part of Miller's retinue
for a long time and is as loyal as they
come the youngest of the Spartan Rangers
Duke is keen to test his abilities but
is known for taking risks new to the
Metro games but the previous character
in the novel series Sam is a former
guard at the US Embassy in Moscow now
Miller's personal bodyguard he is the
eternal optimist and one day dreams of
returning to his homeland America as the
crew medic we can assume we'll be seeing
rather a lot of demure as he patches up
the crew following the inevitable
encounters with the less than friendly
meets in wild life nope no typo there
this chap is in fact named idiot a
nickname he chose apparently it's
actually a reference to a classic novel
by Dostoyevsky which I totally already
need that's why I chose the nickname not
idiots like that weapon you're holding
well that's almost certainly thanks to
talkative he is the crew weaponsmith
armorsmith
and more and is responsible for the
varied cobbled together arsenal onboard
finally there is your Mac he is the
designated driver and has the ideal
resume he is in fact a pre-war train
driver an employee of the Metro
seems like the Aurora is in good hands
there at least there will be many more
characters for our team to meet along
the way in Metro Exodus some friendly
some less so and possibly even some
familiar faces well there's only one way
to find out all aboard the Aurora
[Music]
played on the world's most powerful
console
[Music]